na herzlichen dank für die einladung
hier einen vortrag zu halten
ich werde damit beginnen sie zu bitten
dass sie ihre kamera an lassen wenn
möglich damit ich nicht immer nur in den
bildschirm sprecher sondern mir auch die
menschen die mir zu werden können auch
anschauen kann dafür bedanke ich mich
einfach mal schon mal voraus und fangen
jetzt damit an etwas genauer zu erklären
wie ich überhaupt dazu gekommen bin mich
mit fragen der verantwortung künstlichen
systemen zu beschäftigen nachdem ich vor
langer langer zeit meiner doktorarbeit
mich mal mit handlungsfähigkeit der und
der spezifischen art der kognition
künstliche systeme auseinandergesetzt
habe mich dann aber mehr mit themen der
philosophie des geistes beschäftigt habe
liegt inzwischen mein forschungsbereich
auf soziale kognition an der
schnittstelle von philosophie
psychologie und ki angesichts der vielen
verschiedenen vorschläge philosophische
standard begriffe so zu erweitern dass
dann so dass man damit auch fähigkeiten
von kindern tieren und eben auch
künstlichen systemen erfassen kann war
es für mich jetzt nahelegen mich auch
mal zu fragen welche konsequenzen dies
für themen der praktischen philosophie
hat
denn ich denke dass wir in zukunft einen
großen teil unseres sozialen lebens mit
verschiedenen arten von künstlichen
systemen teilen werden das wird sich
natürlich zu einem großen und
überwiegenden teil in vielen
verschiedenen arten von werkzeuggebrauch
zeigen aber ich denke es ist auch jetzt
schon erkennbar dass es vielleicht
mensch-maschine-interaktion geben kann
wo wir dann auch kollektive personen
finden könnten die sich nicht so einfach
auf werkzeuggebrauch reduzieren lassen
die soziale roboter robotik verfolgt ja
das ziel so genannte companions für
menschen zu entwickeln solche
interaktionen werden dann quasi sozialer
mensch maschine interaktion in denen
sehr ungleiche interaktionspartner
nämlich lebende und nicht leben der
agenten aufeinanderstoßen das impliziert
die these dass bestimmte künstliche
systeme einen neuen typus eines sozialen
agenten darstellen können ob das jetzt
schon so ist und wir dann in
gerechtfertigter weise von soziotop
motiven fähig von künstlichen systemen
sprechen können wird natürlich sehr
kontrovers diskutiert aber
nimmt man mal an dass man das
zumindestens nicht ausschließen kann
dann stellt sich die frage die ich in
diesem vortrag behandelt nämlich ob
künstliche systeme für das ergebnis
sozialer mensch maschine interaktion mit
verantwortlich sein können für
positionen die davon ausgehen dass sich
jeder mensch maschine interaktion auf
werkzeuggebrauch reduzieren lassen und
die deswegen die bloße möglichkeit
künstlichen systemen verantwortung
überhaupt zuzuschreiben von vorneherein
ausschließen stellt sich diese frage
halt nicht aber es gibt inzwischen wie
schon erwähnt vermehrt ansätze die
graduelle konzeption in bezug auf das
thema verantwortung vorschlagen und
sodann auch thesen vertreten unter
welchen umständen künstliche systeme
sich als moralischer agenten
qualifizieren können
bevor ich etwas über verantwortung bei
künstlichen systemen sagen möchte werde
ich in aller kürze etwas zur
verantwortung zuschreibung im
zwischenmenschlichen bereich sagen auch
wenn ich selbst keine expertin der
moralphilosophie bin ich komme ja eher
aus der theoretischen philosophie glaube
ich kann man sagen dass verantwortungs
zuschreibung darauf beruhen ob sich
agenten als moralische agenten
qualifizieren
das heißt es geht darum ob wir
moralische handlungsfähigkeit also
morgen agency zu schreiben können schaut
man sich die bedingungen hierfür an die
dafür erfüllt werden sollen kann man
ziemlich leicht erkennen dass es sich
hier um sehr anspruchsvolle bedingungen
handelt ich nenne hier nur
paradigmatische weise bewusste mentale
zustände internationalität intelligenz
und die fähigkeit zu denken zu planen zu
urteilen und auch anders zu handeln was
vielleicht unser freier wille wenn es
ihn gibt
bewerkstelligt diese bedingung schließen
künstliche systeme wie wir sie jetzt
kennen natürlich von vorneherein aus
wendet man sich dann fragen nach
verteilter verantwortung in mensch
mensch interaktionen zu
menschen kollektive personen sind also
sozusagen gruppen bilden kann man sich
darauf einigen dass die
interaktionspartner sich in irgendeinem
sinne die verantwortung teilen können
damit ist aber natürlich noch nicht
geklärt wie sich die verantwortung
verteilt in meinem vortrag möchte ich
hier zwischen zwei typen von kriterien
unterscheiden
die bei der verteilten verantwortungs
zuschreibung eine rolle spielen
auf der einen seite gibt es kriterien
die ich interaktions bezogene kriterien
nenne bei diesen kriterien geht es darum
welche kognitiven und sozialen motiven
fähigkeiten wir einem
interaktionspartner zu schreiben soweit
ich das übersehen kann geht es hier
neben der bloßen handlungsplanung und
kontrollfähigkeiten auch um soziotop
motive fähigkeiten wie zum beispiel eine
antizipation fähigkeit bezüglich der
konsequenzen einer interaktion im
sozialen bereich und einer antizipation
fähigkeit bezüglich der handlungen der
interaktionspartner was wir philosophen
häufig als mein trading bezeichnen bei
beeinträchtigungen der kognitiven
fähigkeiten kann das ausmaß der
verantwortlichkeit relativiert werden
hier sprechen wir dann von verminderter
schuldfähigkeit nach der deutschen
rechtsprechung können personen unter
gewissen umständen als schuldunfähig
gelten ich zitiere hier den paragrafen
20 schuldunfähigkeit wegen seelischer
störungen aus dem strafgesetzbuch ohne
schuld handelt wer bei begehung der tat
wegen einer krankhaften seelischen
störung wegen einer tiefgreifenden
bewusstseinsstörung
oder wegen einer intelligenzminderung
oder einer anderen schweren seelischen
störung unfähig ist das unrecht der tat
einzusehen oder nach dieser einsicht zu
handeln
neben diesen kriterien gibt es aber auch
noch kriterien die wir aus sozial
konstruierten verantwortungs beziehungen
ableiten können solche kriterien
entscheiden eine bestimmte gewichtung
der verantwortungs verteilung vorgeben
zu können als beispiele kann man hier
verantwortungs beziehungen zwischen
eltern und kindern vorgesetzten und
mitarbeitern oder auch pädagogen und
schutzbefohlenen in der regel spielen
sich hier aber die evaluation der
interaktions personen interaktions
personenbezogenen kriterien wieder jetzt
kommen wir zu den interaktionen zwischen
kindern und erwachsenen denn interessant
für fragen nach verteilter verantwortung
sind interaktionen in den fähigkeiten
ungleich verteilt sind ein paradigma
tisches beispiel für eine asymmetrische
interaktion sind eben
interaktionen zwischen kindern und
erwachsenen
ich gehe da aus dass bei erwachsenen
kind interaktion eine ungleiche
verteilung der verantwortung dadurch
begründet wird dass erwachsene kinder
bezüglich der interaktions bezogenen
kriterien übertreffen schaut man sich
diese kriterien bezüglich der
gewachsenen erwachsenen genauer an
können wir feststellen dass sie weiter
entwickelte fähigkeiten haben als kinder
auch ist die auswahl an möglichen
handlungen größer als bei kindern sie
haben mehr interventionsmöglichkeiten
relevant ist außerdem dass sie über eine
ausgeprägtere antizipation fähigkeit
verfügen nicht nur bezüglich der folgen
der interaktion sondern auch bezüglich
des zukünftigen verhaltens das
interaktionspartner erwachsene sind
sozusagen experten in sozialen
interaktionen währenddessen kinder hier
die rolle von novizen haben deswegen
scheint es auch gerechtfertigt dass
erwachsene mehr verantwortung in bezug
auf das ergebnis einer interaktion
tragen für dieselbe bewertung sprechen
kriterien die man aus gesellschaftlich
etablierten sozial konstruierten
verantwortungs beziehungen ableiten kann
erwachsene insbesondere eltern tragen
einen größeren teil der verantwortung zb
haften eltern für ihre kinder
wenn wir uns jetzt der praxis der
verantwortungs zuschreibungen beim
werkzeuggebrauch zu kann man feststellen
was werkzeug benutzerinnen nicht immer
voll verantwortlich gemacht werden hier
gibt es sowohl externe als auch interne
gründe die eine eingeschränkte
verantwortungs zuweisung rechtfertigen
können neben der schon erwähnten
schuld verminderten schuldfähigkeit
können zum beispiel
widrige umstände wie unvorhersehbare
umweltfaktoren zu einer eingeschränkten
verantwortungs zuschreibung führen in
solchen fällen wird dann oft auch also
aus philosophischer sicht von einer
verantwortung gesprochen auch das
versagen
des technischen ried ist trotz
ordnungsgemäßer handhabe stellt
philosophen häufig vor probleme und wenn
man die herstellerin des technischen
gerätes nicht zur verantwortung zu
ziehen kann dann stellt sich die hier
wieder die frage wo die verbleibende
restschuld eigentlich zu finden ist das
heißt bei werkzeuggebrauch wird die
verantwortung zwischen sozialen
moralischen agenten aufgeteilt und man
ist damit konfrontiert dass es in
manchen fällen verantwortung suppen
geben kann also wenn zb ein hersteller
ganz besonders gute anwälte hat hat man
den eindruck dass dann sozusagen die
restschuld die irgendwo noch im raum
schwebt gar nicht auf die hersteller
mehr zugeschrieben werden kann darf oder
soll
jetzt kommen wir endlich zu den
künstlichen systemen wie sieht es nun
aus bei der verantwortungs zuschreibung
bei den künstlichen systemen die sich
als soziale interaktionspartner
qualifizieren meine these hier ist das
wenn sich künstliche agenten als eine
neue art von sozialen
interaktionspartner qualifizieren können
dann brauchen wir wirklich eine
graduelle begrifflichkeit die diesen
unterschied auch fassen kann
denn wir haben vorher schon gesehen die
anspruchsvollen bedingungen für
vollwertiges moralisches handeln
schließen unbewusste künstliche agenten
von vornherein aus das heißt leider aber
natürlich auch das werden wir uns nicht
auf eine graduelle begrifflichkeit
bezüglich moralischer agenten
verständigen können dann sind die
nachfolgenden überlegungen in einem
gewissen sinne obsolet ich hoffe
natürlich dass dem nicht so ist und
bitte sie vorlesekoffer argument einmal
anzunehmen dass sich moralische
handlungsfähigkeit auf unterschiedliche
arten und weisen realisieren lassen kann
denn nur wenn man hier von einer
möglichkeiten multipler realisierung
ausgeht kann man die notwendigkeit eine
einiger bedingungen des vollwertigen
moralischen handelns überhaupt in frage
stellen es geht hier darum eine
alternative zum begriff des vollwertigen
moralischen handelns zu haben der eben
die künstlichen systeme von vornherein
ausschließt
zum glück muss ich diese jetzt nicht
selber entwickeln sondern kann darauf
verweisen welche vorschläge hier in der
aktuellen debatte gemacht wurden und
auch zeitgründen werde ich auch nicht
auf die einzelnen positionen genauer
eingehen auf den punkt gebracht
ob sie auf den punkt gebracht setze ich
in meinem vortrag eben nicht nur voraus
dass wir den begriff eines sozialen
agenten erweitern können sondern auch
dass der begriff eines moralischen
agenten erweitert werden können für
ersteres habe ich in verschiedenen
aufsätzen schon argumentiert und bin
gerne bereit in der diskussion dann noch
näher darauf einzugehen für letzteres
bitte ich sie mit dem verweis auf wanner
von alan moore in florida and sanders
dies als eine mögliche einnahme
vorauszusetzen
jetzt fehlt nur noch ein ganz kleiner
schritt und dann hoffe ich wird
irgendwie nachvollziehbar warum ich auf
den ersten blick vielleicht eine etwas
abstrus anmutenden
fragestellung aufwerfe auch wenn ich
jetzt nicht in aller ausführlichkeit
dafür argumentieren kann was künstliche
agenten als soziale agenten auszeichnet
und inwiefern sich dieser neue typus
eines sozialen interaktionspartner von
seinen menschlichen pardon unterscheidet
möchte ich festhalten dass künstliche
interaktionspartner nicht über die
gleichen fähigkeiten verfügen wie
menschliche teilnehmer deswegen
bezeichne ich sozialer mensch maschine
interaktion auch als asymmetrische
interaktion
zum 1 kann man natürlich die auffassung
vertreten dass menschen künstliche
interaktionspartner grundsätzlich
übertreffen da künstliche systeme durch
die einführung einer graduellen
begrifflichkeit nur minimale oder auch
einfach anders realisierte bedingungen
erfüllen künstliche agenten sind nicht
lebendig sie haben weder bewusstsein
noch emotionen noch sind sie
leidensfähig es sind alles punkte die
eine gerechtfertigte skepsis gegenüber
verantwortungs zuschreibungen nähern
dazu werden wir sicherlich auch noch
mehr in der diskussion hören aber es
gibt auch fähigkeiten in denen
künstliche systeme menschliche
interaktionspartner übertreffen so
können sie zum beispiel in kürzerer zeit
eine größere menge an daten verarbeiten
und diese auf speichern und relevant für
die folgende überlegung ist auch dass
ihre funktionsweise von menschen nicht
in allen details nachvollziehbar ist das
ist das sogenannte blackbox problem das
darin besteht dass interne prozesse
nicht immer nachvollzogen werden können
das ist im grunde eigentlich so ähnlich
wie es uns gegenüber tieren geht wo wir
auch nicht so genau wissen ob sie oder
was sie denken und fühlen und selbst
gegenüber menschen gibt es ja das
bekannte aber mein problem was wir
vielleicht auch noch nicht schluss
endlich gelöst haben für interaktion mit
künstlichen agenten heißt das dass das
verhalten künstliche agenten nur
eingeschränkt antizipiere ist
hält man sich an dies vor augen kann man
sich jetzt zumindest mal fragen ob
unsere begrenzten fähigkeiten uns in
irgendeinem sinne davon entbinden
könnten einen größeren anteil der
verantwortung in bestimmten sozialen
mensch maschine interaktion zu
übernehmen
kriterien die wir aus sozial
konstruierten verantwortungs beziehungen
ableiten können würden diese frage aber
klar negativ beantworten
wenn sich aber jetzt herausstellen würde
dass eine fallweise bewertung
interaktions bezogenen kriterien für
einen größeren anteil an verantwortung
sprechen kann dann könnte uns das zu der
frage führen ob wir in bezug auf
künstliche systeme die sich als soziale
und moralische agenten qualifizieren
unsere sozial konstruierten
verantwortungs beziehungen vielleicht
noch mal überdenken sollten
um zu veranschaulichen worum es mir geht
wenn ich die frage aufwerfen ob wir
unsere sozial konstruierten
verantwortungs beziehungen noch einmal
überdenken sollten möchte ich ein
fiktives beispiel geben stellen sie sich
dazu bitte eine ganz normale fahrstuhl
stunde vorher interagieren zwei menschen
gemeinsam mit einem werkzeug dem auto
das ist eine gemeinsame handel um einen
joint action in brenzligen situationen
interveniert die fahrlehrerin denn der
fahrschüler kann hier mit einer
kontersituation konfrontiert sein die
seine fähigkeiten übersteigt während die
fahrlehrerin die situation aufgrund
ihrer expertise gut managen kann eine
analyse der interaktion bezogenen
kriterien wird dafür sprechen dass sie
auch dass wir der fahrlehrerin in
solchen situationen mehr verantwortung
zu schreiben zum selben ergebnis kommt
man auch wenn man sich auf kriterien
bezieht die man aus sozial konstruierten
verantwortungs beziehungen ableiten kann
was mich jetzt aber beschäftigt ist
inwiefern sich unserer einschätzung
verändert wenn wir die fahrlehrerin
durch ein fahrerassistenzsystem
ersetzen würden ich gebe zu das ist zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt noch ziemlich
fiktional aber wie würden wir dann über
die verteilung der verantwortung
urteilen ich vermute anhand der
interaktions bezogenen kriterien würden
wir vielleicht zu einer ähnlichen
einschätzung gelangen nur unsere sozial
konstruierten verantwortungs beziehungen
würden hier wohl nur herstellerinnen
oder fahrschülerin als verantwortlicher
ansehen können oder müssten von einer
verantwortungslos sprechen
das heißt man kann fälle konstruieren in
denen die bewertungen der interaktions
bezogenen kriterien in eine ganz andere
richtung zeigen als die bewertung der
kriterien die man aus sozial
konstruierten verantwortungs beziehungen
ableiten kann sie können also
auseinanderfallen denn schaut man auf
die interaktion bezogen den kriterien
bei künstlichen agenten kann man darauf
verweisen dass sie mehr daten aufnehmen
und diese schneller verarbeiten können
und es ist auch möglich dass sie während
der interaktion auf mehr wissen
zugreifen können als ihre menschlichen
interaktion partnerinnen außerdem haben
menschliche interaktion partnerin eine
verringerte antizipation fähigkeit
sowohl bezüglich der folgen der
interaktion als auch bezüglich des
zukünftigen verhaltens der
interaktionspartner
aufgrund dieses ungleichgewicht es
könnte man zu dem urteil gelangt dass es
fälle gibt in denen man sich fragt ob
künstliche agenten mehr verantwortung
zugeschrieben werden können als wir das
in den menschlichen interaktionspartner
in der situation
rechtfertigen können ganz provokativ
formuliert heißt das ob es fälle gibt in
denen menschen quasi die rolle der
kinder innehätten und die künstlichen
systeme quasi die rolle der erwachsenen
wenn er man sich aber wieder den
kriterien zu die man aus unseren
etablierten sozial konstruierten
verantwortungs beziehungen ableiten kann
stellt man fest dass hier nur menschen
verantwortung zugeschrieben wird nämlich
den menschlichen interaktions
partnerinnen oder den herstellerinnen
der kindlich künstlichen systeme
es ist aber
verwunderlich denn unsere etablierten
sozial konstruierten verantwortungs
beziehungen beruhen auf der vorstellung
dass alle mensch maschine interaktion
als fälle von werkzeuggebrauch behandelt
werden können und das habe ich am anfang
meines vortrages mal mit einem
fragezeichen versehen
beim werkzeuggebrauch sind menschen die
haupt adressaten der verantwortung auch
wenn sie die funktionsweise der
werkzeuge nicht vollständig verstehen
oder wenn sie ihre wird selbst wenn sie
in ihrer antizipation fähigkeit
eingeschränkt sein sollen um für einige
kritische fälle vor zusagen vorzusorgen
verlangt unsere gesellschaft ein wissens
nachweis bevor menschen bestimmte
werkzeuge benutzen dürfen zum beispiel
braucht man ja ein führerschein um ein
normales auto zu benutzen
leider ab braucht man keinen
führerschein um im internet unterwegs zu
sein kann man jetzt
überzeugend dafür argumentieren dass
sich aber nicht alle mensch maschine
interaktion aus werkzeuggebrauch
reduzieren lassen und wie es in manchen
fällen mit einem neuen typus einer neuen
sozialen interaktion zu tun haben dann
stellen sich meiner meinung nach viele
verschiedene fragen die gar nicht so
leicht zu beantworten sind
zum beispiel ist es auch in solchen
fällen gerechtfertigt herstellerinnen
künstliche agenten analog zur
produkthaftung bei werkzeugen rostock
verantworten verantwortung zu
zuzuschreiben oder haben graduelle
konzeptionen bezüglich der moralischen
handlungsfähigkeit vielleicht gar keinen
effekt auf die verteilung von
verantwortungen in interaktionen
nimmt man mal an dass bei system den wir
zumindest eine minimale moralische
handlungsfähigkeit zu schreiben die
produkthaftung überdacht werden sollte
und dass eben diese minimalen oder
anders realisierten bedingungen die aus
graduellen konzeption folgen nicht nur
in einem folgenlosen als optisch den
dann hat man meiner meinung nach gute
gründe in bezug auf bestimmte künstliche
systeme die sozial konstruierten
beantwortung beziehungen noch einmal zu
überdenken
mögliche anforderungen zur entwicklung
neuer sozial konstruierter
verantwortungs beziehung möchte ich
daher zu allererstes ziel nennen das
sozial konstruierte verantwortungs
beziehungen zwischen werkzeug gebrauch
und sozialen mensch-maschine-interaktion
differenzieren sollten sie sollten kein
freifahrtschein darstellen um
künstlichen agenten a priori von
jeglicher verantwortung frei zu sprechen
aber
dabei sein sollte man natürlich nicht
die wichtigen übergeordneten
verpflichtungen aus dem blick verlieren
hier könnte man zb die pflicht der
menschen gegenüber künstlichen experten
wachsam und misstrauisch zu sein bevor
sie mit ihnen interagieren nennen oder
auch über eine pflicht der menschen vor
dem umgang mit künstlichen agenten
fachwissen zu erwerben nachdenken ganz
unabhängig davon sollte eine
gesellschaft auch über normative
einschränkungen bezüglich der
herstellung bestimmter systeme
diskutieren und da wären zum beispiel
tötungs drohnen zu nennen vielleicht
wäre es besser wir würden so was gar
nicht bauen
im folgenden geht es jetzt darum wie man
zwischen bloßen bloßen werkzeuggebrauch
und diesem neuen typus einer sozialen
interaktionen unterscheiden kann das ist
alles noch sehr work in progress und ich
freue mich schon sehr auf die
diskussionen und hoffe auf konstruktive
einwände und anregungen
aus dem vergangenen
überlegungen die die rolle von mehr oder
weniger entwickelten socio positiven
fähigkeiten thematisiert haben kann man
schließen dass weiter entwickelte socio
kreative fähigkeiten zu mehr
interventionsmöglichkeiten in konkreten
interaktionen führen das resultiert
wiederum in einem größeren einfluss und
einem höheren maß an kontrolle insofern
denke ich dass das ausmaß an kontrolle
einen wichtigen faktor für
verantwortungs zuschreibungen darstellt
bei dem beispiel der kind erwachsenen
interaktion haben wir ja gesehen dass
die interaktion bezogenen kriterien dem
erwachsenen aufgrund seiner weiter
entwickelten soziotop motiven
fähigkeiten eben mehr verantwortung zu
sprechen ein wichtiger punkt ist hier
dass der erwachsene mehr
interventionsmöglichkeiten hat und
insofern auch mehr kontrolle über den
ausgang der interaktion
schaut man sich als künstliche systeme
an und fragt sich welche sorten von
systemen überhaupt als neue soziale
interaktionspartner in frage kommen kann
man hier zwischen drei typen
unterscheiden das sind zum einen die in
der luft systeme die auf sap systeme und
die on the loop systeme
mit den in de loop system sind systeme
gemeint die vollständig unter
menschlicher kontrolle stehen sie
handeln nicht beeinflussen insofern das
ergebnis der interaktion auch nicht sie
sind ganz normale werkzeuge bei den
sogenannten out of the loop system hat
der mensch außer der initiierung der
interaktion keinerlei
angriffsmöglichkeiten das heißt hier
kann der mensch während der interaktion
keinen einfluss ausüben
interaktionen mit diesen beiden typen
stehen also nicht unter verdacht
dass sie eine soziale interaktion werden
aber es gibt eben auch on the loop
systeme die nicht vollständig unter
menschlicher kontrolle stehen die zu
mindestens über eine minimale
handlungsfähigkeit mit einem gewissen
grad an autonomie anpassungsfähigkeit
und lernfähigkeit verfügen hier
beeinflussen dann beide
interaktionspartner der menschliche und
der künstliche das ergebnis der
interaktion das wäre dann ein neuer
typus einer sozialen interaktion da sich
soziale interaktionen dadurch
auszeichnen dass beide
interaktionspartner in einen einfluss
auf die interaktion haben
bei solchen fragen kann man sich dann
bei
solchen systemen können wir es dann mit
dem neuen typus eines sozialen agenten
zu tun haben und hier stellt sich dann
meiner meinung nach eben die frage nach
der verteilung der verantwortung
so weit so gut jetzt komme ich aber zu
den einwänden
was soll es eigentlich bedeuten
wenn solche agenten verantwortung
zugeschrieben bekommen ohne dass man sie
faktisch zur rechenschaft ziehen können
im zwischenmenschlichen bereich
geht die zuschreibung von verantwortung
in der regel mit der rechtfertigung von
sanktionen und strafen einher
während sanktionen oder bestrafung in
bezug auf künstliche akteure nur schwer
vorstellbar sind wenn nicht undenkbar
gibt es hier wohl einen kategorischen
unterschied zwischen menschen und diesen
neuen typus eines sozialen interaktion
partners
in anbetracht des fehlens möglicher
sanktionsmaßnahmen scheint das
allgemeine projekt künstlichen agenten
verantwortung zuzuschreiben zu scheitern
weder ein gradueller begriff von
moralischer handlungsfähigkeit noch die
zuschreibung minimaler soziotop aktiver
fähigkeiten wie etwa einer minimalen
fähigkeit zu gemeinsamem handeln klären
hier welche konsequenzen aus diesen
zuschreibungen für verantwortungs
zuschreibung folgen könnte aber es ist
auch offensichtlich dass das projekt
moralisches handeln als graduelle es
phänomen zu fassen viel weitreichendere
konsequenzen nach sich ziehen könnte als
man vielleicht anfangs gedacht hatte es
könnte uns nämlich dazu bringen den
engen zusammenhang zwischen
verantwortung und möglichen sanktionen
zu hinterfragen zukünftige forschung
sollte daher untersuchen inwieweit
künstliche systeme ihre verantwortung
gerecht werden können wenn sie
beispielsweise mit einer
haftpflichtversicherung
ausgestattet werden
eine weitere schwierigkeit ergibt sich
aus dem umstand dass unsere
kontinuierliche existenz als soziale
agenten eine wesentliche rolle in
unserer praxis des umgangs mit
verantwortungs zuschreibungen spielt
menschen erweisen sich
nicht nur während einer sozialen
interaktion als verantwortlich die
verantwortung geht in der regel darüber
hinaus sie verfügen über eine personale
identität wie wir in den vorigen
vorträgen schon gehört haben die man zum
beispiel durch die psychologischen
verbindung die wir zwischen unserem hier
und jetzt um unserem zukünftigen und
vergangenen selbst besteht definieren
kann auch hier tut sich wiederum ein
kategorialen unterschied zwischen
lebenden und nicht lebenden wiesen auf
die künstliche agenten die sich gerade
nicht in einer sozialen interaktion
befinden zb ausgeschaltet im schrank
stehen zu beurteilen sind bleibt an
dieser stelle auch eine offene frage
die zugegebenermaßen etwas provokative
ausgangsfrage war kann es sozialer
mensch maschine interaktion geben in
denen menschen weniger verantwortung
zukommt als ihren künstlichen
interaktionspartner
ich hoffe ich habe zumindestens
überzeugen können dass es nicht
ausgeschlossen ist dass es soziale
mensch-maschine-interaktion geben kann
die sich nicht so einfach auf bloßen
werkzeuggebrauch reduzieren lässt meine
analyse
interaktions bezogener kriterien sollte
zeigen wann wir vielleicht geneigt wären
diesen neuen typus sozialer agenten mehr
verantwortung als dem menschlichen
interaktionspartner zu zuschreiben kann
man dieser analyse folgen dann ergeben
sich gründe unsere sozial konstruierten
verantwortungs beziehung noch einmal zu
überdenken
jedoch zeigt sich bei der diskussion von
einwenden dass hier noch viel arbeit vor
uns liegt bis wir in der lage sind einen
neuen typus eines interaktionspartner
mit all seinen ethischen konsequenzen
mit zu berücksichtigen
aber es wird auch offensichtlich dass
das projekt moralisches handeln als
graduelle phänomen zu fassen viel
weitreichendere konsequenzen nach sich
ziehen könnte als wir am anfang
vielleicht gedacht haben es könnte uns
dazu bringen den engen zusammenhang
zwischen verantwortung und möglichen
sanktionen zu hinterfragen zukünftige
forschung sollte daher untersuchen
inwieweit künstliche systeme nicht nur
verantwortung zugeschrieben werden kann
sondern auch wie sie ihrer verantwortung
gerecht werden können
ich bedanke mich sehr für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auf
kritische fragen